[Music]
what do i call asymmetrical multiplayer
game yes um I guess it's nothing like it
but if you want to go back to maybe like
left 4 dead or no sorry evolve one
person versus 4 in this case it is Jason
Voorhees vs. 4 of the Camp Crystal Lake
teenagers if you are familiar with those
between each camp counselor we if the
Friday the 13th movies it comes out
Friday
but we've been people in our office
about playing the last couple days so
incredibly bored I was so bored
yeah I mean like so Peter you touched on
this in your review like when you first
start playing if you die early like if
you're a counselor and you die early you
could be waiting for like 15 minutes and
just spectating yeah um and that's
boring but also like I just I didn't
actually like the the task of trying to
escape and protect myself like just kind
of you know running through this camp
and I I just was so bored like I just
kind of like hung out in the closet and
waited for you to come kill me Peter was
like Jason like six times and sorry
Peter you go ahead I was going to say
that totally valid like I survived a few
matches by playing a stealthy character
and just camping in a tent which wow
that's the perfect use of that that
phrase uh but uh you know it's one of
those scenarios where it's like alright
well so what's what's the point of
playing is the point of playing just to
amass experience points and not die or
is it to try to like to get crafty you
know and avoid death at the hands of
this dude who has crazy advantages I
think you have to be you have to go into
this looking for that kind of experience
where you know the odds are stacked
against you and you're going to have to
scrounge and be stealthy it essentially
do things that are kind of stressful and
will make you you know worried moment to
moment or you could just do this right
but I just don't feel like there's
enough I don't feel like there's enough
to the the movement in the act of
scrounging around to make and compelling
so it's like oh I find a flare gun I can
only carry one thing which is like fine
that could be interesting but I just
feel like it's something with the
movement or something is it
I use a there's not enough there for me
it does a really bad job of explaining
the different options you have available
to you so the whole point is there's a
fixed amount of time the counselors
either have to survive before Jason
kills them for the clock runs out or
find a way to escape the camp and
escaping the camp means finding items to
fix vehicles but that's never really
explained to you and you're not going to
just sort of figure that out maybe you
could but but but immediately you just
know that you need to hide right so your
first thought is not going to be like I
need to find a car and see what parts I
need and those and there are your
objectives that's the only time it like
explains other than the intro like how
to play but like despite this info being
given you're right like as far as you've
no idea where the stuff is or how to
find it yeah I mean you have to go
through a lot of matches that are boring
or you die a lot right to get to the
point where you you kind of understand
the lay of the land is that worth it
like what's compelling me I don't mean
to be like antagonistic I was like no I
I have so many other games to play and
like yes things I want to do why should
I have to go through all these boring
matches where I mean like we got kicked
so many times yeah yesterday trying just
to play yeah where I was like I why
would I put up with this when I could be
doing literally anything else no well
and and that's the other valid point is
that we had a lot of connection problems
yeah yeah we were getting different
matches all the time and it was making
it kind of frustrating to get it to
match and I think Kelly you make an
excellent point
you know it's what did it for and that's
all I can really explain is what did it
for me cuz I was definitely like put out
for my first few matches as counselor
but once I got to play as Jason I kind
of understood the dynamic between the
two sides a little bit better and maybe
I could see the mistakes that I had been
making through the eyes of Jason which
which then led me to think about the
game differently when I was a counselor
yeah Phares that's that's interesting to
me like that's the only thing that has
hooked me is hearing that from you
that's the only reason I would want to
try to keep playing the viola and and
and this is where I was mentioning
earlier is like for me it got
interesting was when like Peter and I
last night and a couple of other people
in the office which played late and we
were actually finally talking with other
people and chatting
unlike what we do I have the gas tank
come to me and this is footage of my
play like towards the end last night was
the first time as counselor I won and it
was a pretty funny story where Nick
margarita was playing and this one this
woman over here was like she got the
battery she brought up a car and then I
had rain a stamina so I'm from a hilltop
I'm looking down in Jason's killing her
but she got the battery to the car
engine and died I'm like no crap Michael
in there and I met up with two other
people we had a gas tank they had the
keys we're putting the gas tank or point
gas into the car doing a little mini
game and if you fail the mini game or
are stalling the mini game then Jason
like hears you so I was pretty awesome
I did like a flawless gas tank filled
yes I'm hella good this is me oh by the
way I am the dogs character I did I did
the mocap and that is a my own cardigans
so here's that this is a first footage
of it but um the thing was I was I
getting out I'm sorry later huh all this
let's play out but so as I'm doing this
yeah the you you were covering your
buddies that's Nick Margaery there with
the plaid with a flare gun and so the
male so snick didn't know how to play so
the fight it was then like Nick runs
over the front and he gets a battery and
he starts hooking it up and right now
you you're slowly hearing the Jason
music build because he is getting closer
and closer so it's making that mini game
very stressful so I'm here like I got
the flare gun so next to it and Nick is
in the office and Nick's going damn it
yes all I meanwhile he's alerting Jason
to know exactly where we are
and let it play out but the point being
is that this is a very centred or here
comes so though Jason is just here so
now so by the way the here is he's
coming so by the way this is a
two-seater car three of us where's Jason
I assume in the head where I love that
that's all that wait you didn't know who
that that's Raymond of nowhere took the
guy
like levears best part it's a nick who
helps for the Burien leptin mine if you
can't tell us this game is a rough
around the edges but it's almost I mean
do you guys play dead by daylight
earlier this year or last year sorry um
that game same idea asymmetrical horror
there were different killers but that
was the only way to escape was to
activate these generators dials just
said genitals on accident oh my yeah
well whatever uh you had to activate
generators to escape this site whatever
map they lay down this there are more
options available and it's also a
million on like more focused on Friday
13th but it seems like kind of almost in
the same vein of battlegrounds I think
battlegrounds more polished seems like
very much so especially getting into it
out of matches but seems rough around
the edges but they're like the emergent
situations like Nick margarita running
next to the car when yeah he did alt
like most of the boys that's all just
right out of Jason I wasn't I wasn't
here for that I had yeah so that makes
me want to try this game again right
experience something like that I just my
first impression was really bad now and
we were on the same boat like we were
all there but we decided early car in
the office you shouted this is a dud I
remember and then it got better yeah we
had a lot of fun yesterday playing with
randoms oh right who were really
antagonist ik but then we like got them
to like come on our side and like joke
around with us and then so rob was
playing as Jason and the whole point was
that we were like just gonna just be
friends we work at it no one's gonna try
to kill anyone we was gonna go around
the campfire
and but meanwhile I'm telling Robin like
alright just you can kill that but just
don't kill me yeah it's so like like
slowly one by one he starts killing
people and then we like run off and I
find you and you just like murder me and
it was like this gets comedic scenario
in a game that's meant to be horrifying
and it just comes down to the people
playing it you know like it's a great
thing for for that I again expecting a
lot just like backgrounds a lot of
streams and like like funny pranks like
again like this the same instance where
I'm Jason I'm still engaging Jed I'm
like hey guys I'm making a campfire
we're gonna cook up some chili and they
all know you're actual Jason voice that
I heard for like three hours yesterday
it was I sit next to Romney off oh you
were doing he's doing like I made chili
Oh guys I made chili and then there is I
met a bunch of snake boys boys let's
just separate a Jewish oh great a lot of
characters there came out yesterday but
they're all like they all show up and
they're all really timid and I'm Jason
at this campfire and they're like wait
are you sure you're not ghosts I'm like
I'm totally not gonna kill you missing
chili and then and then we're all there
and it's like what do you actually do am
i obviously can't make chili in the game
so we're standing there I go I just go
hey guys guess what I go no I go hey
guys guess what and one of the shotgun
goes to shoots me stuns me I was like I
look at it it's blood like so you're I
would expect a lot of again like streams
and funny kind of like viral stuff this
game needs work clearly he's a lot of
work it needs a lot of work around
eyeballs where there is no the
animations are so like there's really
gently eyeballs they're janky and it's
it's funny is it's on the level of like
bad b-movie slasher films I would say to
an extent work that you could kind of it
was on purpose I'm not saying it was on
purpose
I'm not saying was on purpose but what I
am saying is that it kind of makes it so
dumb and fun like in that respect I'm
seeing that that character we just saw
every cutscene beginning he just turns
around and it's the most it's like the
most obnoxious face uh yeah my how was
the balance like cuz my initial
impression from playing it a few months
ago was that
I mean he's supposed to be but Jason was
very very overpowered and I guess that
fits also so part of it is really just
if you just sort of like hide you're not
gonna find things like firecrackers or
the flare gun or stuff like that things
that can actually give you an advantage
to get away from Jason you can step bear
traps there's a lot of things you can do
he is pretty overpowered but part of the
game is managing as a counselor like how
often you move how rushed you are how
much fear you're giving off because
those are the sort of things that he
senses now there are also other
characters right so there's a girl I
unlocked who has 10 out of 10 stealth
there was one time where I was literally
crouched in a room and Jason just
looking around and I couldn't see me so
you can find ways to get around it you
just have to like spend enough time to
understand that the tools available to
you okay how you unlock new campers yeah
oh one one annoying thing that I
overheard you guys saying is unlike
battlegrounds which you die a lot in you
can leave the match right away once you
die in this you have to wait out the
rest of the match to get experience late
that's your saying oh right you two talk
about that okay you can that sounds
annoying as hell I'm lead well you're
gonna lose all or a good is this bermed
right you're gonna lose a good amount of
your experience I have a scene
experience get added on yeah believe in
oh man so it's one experience to unlock
the better things you have to like stick
around I was like answering emails and
doing my makeup yeah okay and you might
as well because I think you get at least
500 experience points for finishing a
match by just waiting it out that's
enough to roll a random perk right so
like you might as well just do that so
you can get a random ability to tap on
your characters because you start with
none yeah and you know there is a chance
you'll be resurrected as a character
who's got like really high stats and a
shotgun but that's not guarantee that's
up to the players in the game to do
something to activate that it had weird
someone did kind of bring that up like
within the first beginning moments of
the game like Jason gets stronger and
stronger right yes so you know it may be
you could be that lone wanderer and hide
intent the whole time but it could be
detrimental in the end because he can
eventually just like find you yeah
that's true
your review and progress will be up
today manage huh it is awesome
we're working on a video review to go
with that
but the full review should be next week
sometime I got Tekken 7 in ya inviting
my time between Tekken 7 Dan Friday 13th
[Music]